In this Cloud Minute, I want to show you how to resize a persistent disk without downtime
Here, I have a Compute Engine VM called my-instance
It has a disk attached called my-disk
Let's click on my-disk and take a look at its size
It's 100 GB
Let's go back to our instance and SSH into it
Look at the disk size using "df -h" command
Now, let's go back to console and double our disk size
Click on the disk
Click edit
Change size to 200
Hit Save
After you resize your disk, you must resize your partition
so that operating system can access the additional space
Let's do that using "resize2fs" command
Note that you didn't have to reboot or even start a new shell
Now, let's see that it is resized
That's it! Thanks for watching